with the odd life of Timothy green this
week more than likely causing lots of
birds and bees discussion with parents
all around the world with their children
and now ParaNorman having more adult
humor than any family film I have ever
seen children everywhere are very
confused this week ParaNorman is the new
stop-motion animated film from the
makers of Coraline another stop-motion
animated film and one of my favorite
animated films I use visual aids today
I'm proud of myself
I deserve a gold star now ParaNorman is
a movie that I knew nothing about I've
been trying an experiment lately where I
purposely do not watch any trailers
before I see the movie I've tried to do
that there's been some films where I've
just you know I've broken I've watched
the trailers for then somewhere I don't
really care but I decided to look at
paranormal I was like you know what that
movie could have potential for being
great I'm not gonna watch any trailers I
want to go to that movie blind and this
movie blew me away
I was so surprised by this movie this is
the biggest surprise for me this year
I loved ParaNorman it was such a clever
unique family film very similar in the
vein of Coraline very creepy and
actually a little bit scary and
suspenseful excellent visuals and
amazing stop-motion animation this movie
is about a kid his name is Norman and he
has the ability to see people who are
dead all around him and always not
Hitler Joel Osment from The Sixth Sense
he's perfectly acceptable this and he
likes it I mean he actually talked to
these people and they're his main
friends because everyone in life thinks
he's really strange and creepy and no
one really hangs out with him even his
own family soon he discovers he's the
only person who can stop this curse from
coming upon his town because he's the
only person who can talk to the dead to
get them to stop and get this curse to
go away that's when our adventure with
Norman starts and we get to see how he's
going to try to get out of this
situation I'm a big fan of the animation
because simply I just respect the amount
of time that goes into that I mean to
literally sit there and just move all
these figures all day and the creation
of the figures - it's all so complex I
have such respect for the people who
work on that type of animation and I'm
always blown away by the seamless
quality of the animation of these movies
nowadays I honestly had like this big
geeky smile on my face throughout almost
this entire movie like every scene was
so unique and clever and I just I'm
blown away by this animation it's so
beautiful but the creepiness of this
movie was something I just
listed who was so strange and weird it
had this great spoof of the 80s slasher
movies or the 80s zombie movies where it
seemed like there was always this really
intense symphonic electronic score in
the background like Halloween for
instance and they even spoof Halloween
at one point in this movie like whenever
the zombies are on screen or coming
through the doors of the windows there's
this great music in the background dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun it
was so cool it was just such a throwback
to that old type of horror movie where
like all the scores were always
symphonic it's just I loved it the
character of Norman is so great - he's
voiced by Kodi smit-mcphee from Let Me
In who was really good in that movie
he's really good here - I really want to
see what else this kid can do he's a
good actor I'm excited to see what else
he can do he was really good as Norman
his voice was just you it was great like
the main word I can think to describe
this movie is unique because everything
about this movie is just so different
and original he could tell that a lot of
these filmmakers we're trying to do
something different or outside of the
box and I like that they were doing that
with this movie and I was really
impressed also he's got this buddy in
this movie he's a larger kid he was so
funny in this movie all these jokes were
hitting there is a lot of adult humor in
this movie I cannot believe how much
they actually got away with this movie
maybe on the border of breaching into
the pg-13 area I was extremely impressed
I loved it it was great
I had a lot of fun with ParaNorman my
only issue I have with the film is that
about halfway through the movie it slows
down for like a 15 minute period not
because it's boring or all of a sudden
it just the movie was writing it's such
a great pace of comedy and suspense it
kind of slowed down for a little bit but
then it picked up again very quickly
that's my only issue with the movie I'm
gonna give ParaNorman an a - it's
actually one of my favorite films so far
this year and maybe try doing what I did
if you haven't seen a trailer yet try
not watching one at all and just going
into the movie as blind as possible you
might find yourself enjoying it just
like I did and as always guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my eyes